how's it going red my name is boom ah
welcome back to some dancin let's get
this mouse out of the way sorry gal it's
been a while since I did some dancing
you bros wanted me to dance Gangnam
style but I thought you know what
there's a lot of song that we haven't
done here yet so let's warm up with
these I wanted to do I found an Indian
song that I thought was pretty funny
alright Mayotte yeah - do it - so you
can pass a line that's great it's gonna
be good alright here we go
it hasn't even started yet I don't know
okay all right we're doing it breath
what the No
yeah I wish I know the legs so much oh
maybe I can read the legs all right that
factory kudos me does it make sense
anyway oh it's not even clapping
[Music]
I don't know - me exercise it
takes the do this
oh alright let's just do it alright
I got this
got this all right
barrels this one is for you that's gonna
be difficult
oh my god what is this oh good here the
bug
oh my god I'm not gonna make this I
think I'll die from a heart attack
with the boom boom into my heart this is
not gay I don't know what gay is since
I'm students but that's my thing
and you don't bang bang ended up in the
same but it's not cheap
nah nah nah nah keeps me good my baby
love birthday we don't kill his yelling
plan where you go before you get with me
yeah bake me Bobo you go go don't leave
me perfect they're just ah wake me up Oh
what the hell is this what am i dying
Bennett's
dancing decision oh you see the hit
this is why you don't have this is thank
you I'm sick
holy a sister do Gangnam
style and get it over with all right
here we go
oh god what's that the hell is the hip
good moustache Wow
son of a my cheek now what I hate
about topical things I'm doing you know
yeah
[Music]
gormogon us down there we go there we go
I think I got it whooping guns down
I got it I totally got it go whoa gotta
go down I'm too tired for this yeah but
wouldn't go down put you okay
last bit of energy left
[Music]
[Applause]
I totally got this - sexy pew yeah all
right
trying to shower anyway I can pray it's
kind of come over today
yeah next episode of I'm a South man
don't you die Reagan a Who am I
I don't know actually what's your name
oh it's an EB
my name is Calvert
wait you are clever but all this time
you are clever rod